welcome to level three exponents let's
get started
so if i asked you what four
to the one-half power is
your immediate inclination is to view
this probably as like a multiplication
problem and try to multiply it somehow
or or or add them or something and and
you always have to remind yourself this
is not multiplication i i know when i
first learned it i always was tempted to
do something with multiplication
well something to the one half power
might not be intuitive to you but it
actually turns out that this means the
same thing as the square root of 4
or another way what times
itself is equal to 4 and we know that
the square root of 4 is 2.
it could actually be a positive 2 or a
negative 2 because we both we know that
either of those numbers when they're
squared could equal 4. but for for the
sake of this one we'll assume it's
always the positive square root so 4 to
the one-half
is equal to two
similarly
nine
to the one-half
well that would be three
sixteen
to the one-half
now whoops sixteen to the one-half i my
subconscious gave away the answer 16 to
the one half power is four
25
to the one-half power
is
five
i think that might make sense to you now
so what does it mean when something is
to the one-third power
well if i say eight
to the one-third power
you might already catch on in the
one-half power we said something times
something is equal to four
well in the one-third power we have to
say that
something to the third power is equal to
eight and if you've been practicing
exponents you know that two to the third
power is equal to eight
so we know that two
eight to the one third is equal to two
similarly
twenty-seven
to the one-third
is equal to
three and sixty-four
to the one-third
is equal to 4. you might notice that i'm
picking particular numbers like 8 and 27
and 64. that's because they have clean
cube roots and by the way when something
is to the one-third power that's the
same thing as saying the cube root i
just use terminology without explaining
it which is very bad
so i just used 8 and 27 and 64 because
when i raise them to the fractional
exponents they actually come out to be
clean numbers you could use a calculator
and do something like 5 to the one third
power and you'll get some weird decimal
let's do some more problems
so we know that
nine
to the one-half
is equal to three
well what do you think 9
to the 2 thirds is equal to
well it turns out that this is
equivalent to
9 to the
oh whoops i actually didn't want to do 9
to 2 thirds what do you think
9 to the 3 halves
is equivalent to
well this is the same thing as 9
to the one-half power
to the third power and i'll do a whole
presentation on exponent
the actual principles of exponents
but it it actually turns out you can
just multiply when you have one exponent
to another exponent you can multiply the
two and that's where we get three halves
but nine to the one half we know is
three 3
and raising that to the third power so
that equals 27 i'm sure at this point i
have confused you let's do more of these
so you know at this point that
16
to the one-fourth power think about what
that is that means that some number to
the fourth power is 16
and if you've been practicing your level
1 exponents you'll probably know that
well that equals 2 because 2 times 2
times two times two well that equals
sixteen so we know that sixteen to the
one fourth is equal to two
so what do you think sixteen
to the two fourths is equal to
well we already know from that last
problem that that's the same thing as
16 to the 1 4
squared that's the 2 on both sides and
we know 16 to the 1 4 is 2 so that
equals 2
squared and that equals 4.
and it all works out because
we know from fractions another way to
write the fraction two-fourths is to
write one-half so this is the same thing
as 16 to the one-half power
and 16 to the one-half power well well
that's just equal to four
now i'm going to mix it up real good and
do some fraction negative fractional
exponents
so what if i were to tell you 16
to the negative one-half power
well this might seem very daunting at
first but as we know with the negative
exponents level three immediately we
just say well this is the same thing as
one over 16
1 over 16
to the positive one-half
and that's the same thing as one to the
one-half
over sixteen to the one-half
well the square root of one is easy it's
one and sixteen to the one-half is four
so that wasn't too bad it's a little
daunting when you see a negative
exponent but immediately when you see
that negative just flip the 16
and then work it out like a regular
fractional exponent problem let's do
another one
eight
over
twenty seven
to the
let's say
negative
one third 3.
immediately when we see that negative we
want to just flip it so we'll say that
equals 27
over 8
to the one-third
and that equals 27
to the one-third
over
eight to the one-third
and we know that 27 to the one-third
well that equals three
and eight to the one-third well that
equals two two so we've got three halves
so we got eight over twenty seven to the
negative one third is three halves this
first problem probably looked very
intimidating to you but only took us two
steps to get there and as you do more
practice it hopefully it'll seem more
and more intuitive to you let me give
you another problem
what's negative 8
to the negative third power
no no actually
let me change that what's negative 8
to the negative
1 3 power
and once again at first this might
confuse you but when you see that
negative in the exponent we just take
the reciprocal of the base so that we
say that that is equal to
negative 1 over 8
negative 1 over 8
to the 1 3 power
and we say well that is equal to
we could write it as
we could write it as 1 over negative 8
to the one third
we say what number times itself three
times is equal to negative eight
well we know from intuition there's no
real mechanical way to do this is but we
know that negative two times negative
two is four times negative two is
negative eight so we know that this is
equal to
one over negative two
or
negative one half
so eight negative eight to the negative
one third is equal to minus one half
let's do another one one more problem
just to
thoroughly melt your brain
let's say a
nine over four
to the
negative
3
over 2.
well immediately we see that negative
exponent
let's flip the base we get 4 over 9
to the three-halves
well we know that that equals
four
over nine
to the one-half
and then all of that
to the third power
four over nine to the one half i think
at this point you know that's the same
thing as four to the one half which is
two
over nine to the one half which is three
and then we have to just raise
everything to the third power
and that's the same thing as two to the
third power which is eight
that's an eight
sometimes the computer acts funny
divided by three to the third power
that's 27.
there we have nine fourths to the
negative three halves power is equal to
eight over 27.
now hopefully you can at least do these
problems and you probably don't have a
good intuitive sense for
for exactly what a negative three half
power is and hopefully i can i can cover
that for you in future modules but i
think you're ready to try some of the
level three exponent practice problems
have fun